[Music]
[Applause]
I'm here talking with Alison Kirby of
GDC listen thanks for joining us at the
FTTH conference here
tell us about your the business model
and how you did the separation okay well
TDC was taken private just under a year
ago by a consortium of Macquarie the
infrastructure and real estate arm of
Macquarie er that really invests
particularly into infrastructure over
long term horizons and named three of
the leading pension funds in Denmark and
it was their ambition to buy TDC and
split it into an echo that was focused
on building out high-speed technologies
whether it be in fix or mobiles or fiber
or 5g for the benefit of all of the
service providers in in Denmark and then
splitting splitting off the OP core as
we just you know we we named it
yesterday it's now going to be called
new day and they were creating a digital
service provider that aggregates all of
the digital services that a Danish
individual household or enterprise might
want to live their digital lives you
know these
the orders that we have have a very very
long-term investment horizon and they
fundamentally believe in that fiber is
is utility like in nature you have to
have a long-term investment horizon to
to be able to wait for the returns to
come 15 years plus and they have a
history of investing in infrastructure
and other utilities they also believe
like I do that increasingly price access
to high-speed networks is just becoming
as important as electricity and water to
the average consumer and so they believe
over time as we increasingly need to
invest in these new technologies whether
it be five r5g
to get the return on investment you
probably need one national
infrastructure and that's what we're now
building o in in debt
so we're accelerating the fiber
investment that CDC under its previous
ownership could never afford because the
owners didn't have the long-term
investment horizon and were accelerating
the separation the legal separation of
the two companies happens this summer so
what's the view from your perspective on
on open access for example in this area
well our strategic choice is to open up
our infrastructure to always so our
model is that we will be a wholesaler of
fixed and mobile technologies and the
best technologies for all service
providers in Denmark and that's the
that's the way myself and our owners
believe that they will get an economic
return on that investment and we believe
that's the fastest way for countries to
get access to high-speed technologies to
support the digital demands of their
population well it sounds like a great
organization to be leading thank you
very much for talking to us very welcome
lovely to be here thank you
[Music]
you